is unitary quantum mechanics consistent
with born probability
so you've all heard in a series of
previous talks uh reference to the fact
that uh the time development in in
quantum mechanics is unitary and then
everybody mentions at some point um that
the pro that it gives probabilities
uh for most outcomes and that the
probabilities are described by the born
rule that is to go as the measure of the
quantum state corresponding to some
outcome or
in
some simple cases as psi squared
so what i want to do here is first of
all warn you absolutely nothing i'm
going to say here is original
and what i want to talk about is
two things first is
to show that the excuses that are often
given
for
saying that the born probability
is provably
the right probability to use with
unitary quantum mechanics
all have
hidden or sometimes explicit anthropic
arguments
behind them
and that in fact
unitary quantum mechanics really looks
on the surface
to be quite inconsistent with the born
probability
or with any probability
that would make any sense to us
and then the second half will be an
advertisement for jacques mala's many
computations
interpretation of quantum mechanics
of in which he gives an explicit
argument
for why
born probabilities could arise
naturally not that they must not that
they're provably required but that they
could requ
arise
conditionally dependent on what the
quantum state is
so that's that's the outline of what
um just i think most people know this
but uh jamie said give an introduction
for the non-quantum people the quantum
state is a vector in hilbert space time
evolution is given by a unitary operator
uh like a generalization of the
schrodinger equation
um
the local description of what's going on
is not given in general by a pure state
but by a trace over the environment with
which the vocal state is uh entangled
and that's described by a density matrix
and um
if that's the whole story there's no
little foaming dot or
uh alleged collapse process or anything
like that then all the possible outcomes
that are allowed by that unitary
development
in some sense occur
but they turn into
d coherent pieces pieces
which no longer
exhibit of any quantum interference
effects at least as measured by any sort
of
more or less local measurement and those
distinct pieces are called many worlds
and this is
uh
the pure unitary development is usually
described as the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
now the point is the unitary development
itself has no probability in it at all
it's completely deterministic so the
question is where does the probability
come from
and once you've
made an excuse for having some
probability
why is that probability proportional to
the quantum measure the size squared
rule the born rule
so let's look first
at a
toy case the toy case that everybody
starts with when they start thinking
about what should we see with many
worlds ever it started with this and so
on
let's look at the uh schroedinger cat
experiment where
it is driven by a quantum measurement of
the spin
and if the spin is measured to be up
along some chosen axis
then the cat is allowed to live
if the spin is measured to be down then
the cat is killed
and this experiment can be repeated on a
large number of cats i'm not
recommending anybody do that but you
know in principle the donkey
experiment can be done
we could for example start with the
initial spin
lined up
we'll try and be a little bit nice make
it line up a little more with the up
axis than with the down axis you know
the sum of the squares adds up to one so
it could be a probability of one squared
and we start with a cat
in some sort of environment
which consists of everything around
everything that might interact by any
field with the cat and since cats have
gravity it's everything
um and then
the measurement process just consists of
what
we've heard called an instrument it's
some sort of a
process by which
the interaction just ordinary quantum
process where the interaction of the cat
with the environment
leads to
a change in the environment depending uh
changing the cap and the environment the
spin up gives the live cap
with an environment that might include
you and certainly everything that
interacts gravitationally that sees the
lives live cat plus there's a component
of with a
spin down
a dead cat in an environment that sees a
dead cat
and here's the part where
everybody
gets surprised when they first think
about it
and either gives up on many worlds or
finds some excuse to sort of talk their
way over
each of these uh
results is perfectly experienceable you
don't tell yourself huh i'm not
fully experiencing this because my
coefficient is 0.6
so each each of these
is a perfectly good world
you do this experiment on a large number
of cats you end up with many different
worlds they're all distinguishable
because they all have different live
cats in them
and as you look
in the number of times you've done this
type of experiment get to be big
you can just count worlds and of course
the binomial expression almost all the
worlds have about 50 of the cats
live
but we've set this up
so that we know that's not the actual
result
of real experiments we've set it up so
that 64
of the time the cat lives and if you've
done many many
experiments just ordinary classical
statistics
sets in and you will find most of the
time you're over here with about 64 like
not at 50
so you don't get the probabilities in
the obvious way by just counting how
many worlds look one way and how many
worlds look another way somehow or other
the quantum measure has snuck in in a
way that
is surprising
so let me just say a little bit about
what what those worlds are because
there's a certain fuzziness about the
definition of worlds and i just
point you to the uh standard explanation
of it which is vojtek zurich's so-called
ein selection environmentally induced
selection where certain types of states
of the local system
of are
give sort of stable elements of the
density matrix in the sense that
they don't really care
at least for
moderate length time what's going on in
the outside world with which
your local system is entangled so for
example
if you have a
live cat or could be a dead cat and its
density matrix is
represented this way in a live cat dead
cat
basis
then
for a little while it's going to
continue to look the same this density
matrix will be reasonably stable
if on the other hand you've sort of
perversely picked as your basis
states
live cap plus dead cat over route 2
and live cat minus dead cat over route 2
which from the point of view of hilbert
space are just fine
states nothing wrong with them
as local states
all hell breaks loose when you look at
the density matrix over time you get
these off diagonal terms that are
fluctuating all over the place uh
depending on things that are going on
remotely and with things that you're
entangled with that you have no control
over and can't really detect
so
the so-called pointer states the one
that corresponds
to
the type of macroscopically
coherent outcomes that we are used to
thinking about
and experiencing those are
selected not by the structure of hilbert
space but by the structure of this
interaction with the environment
so um
let's see uh
what happens as time goes forward let's
say you start off with the pure state
expressed in some funny basis where
there's a whole bunch of off-diagonal
terms
of
in in
writing the density matrix for that
state because you picked just sort of a
random basis what happens is
time goes forward
well the intent increasing entanglement
with the outside world
causes
the off-diagonal terms that connect
versions of the outcome that are
microscopically distinct
to essentially vanish
and as time goes forward then you get
off diagonal terms only between things
that are macroscopically closer and
closer to each other
so
that's the basic
standard picture of what's going on with
decoherence
and the emergence of
classical reality from the quantum
underlying picture
so definitely not seeing it saying
anything new here
now what happens when you have two
really
distinct states
backwards think the life state and the
dead state
um
and there are essentially no
soft diagonal terms uh between them you
know in other words you're not going to
get any quantum interference terms
between these macroscopically uh
distinct states
we set it up so that this guy had a
coefficient of 0.8 and that one had a
coefficient of 0.6 now we're in 64
probability here 36 probability there
but why
the internal structure of this density
matrix
it's not in any systematic way different
from the internal structure of that
density matrix
whatever your rule is for counting how
many experiences there are other than
for the cat of course
within
this that are represented by this
piece of the density matrix and they're
represented by that piece of the density
matrix there's no systematic reason for
there to be more here than there
so
there's nothing about what i've said so
far that would break that initial toy
argument that says
uh
we should end up with equal number of
live cats and dead cats uh regardless of
the exact
orientation of the initial spin that
went into that measurement problem which
would
make those coefficients different from
0.6 or
0.8
so we still haven't accounted for how it
is
that the born probabilities
can arise in any natural way from this
purely unitary
time evolution of a quantum state in a
environment
let's look at a little bit at the sort
of problems that would come up if we
look if we just try and count worlds
the live cat
might have quantum fleets
and within their
brains
little police have small brains so their
small quantum events are causing them to
decide to jump or not to jump but those
are microscopically distinct states
so the live cat is turning into a whole
bunch of macroscopically distinct cats
depending on
the quantum branching of each of those
fleas
and they had
if we just tried counting worlds that
would lead to something very strange
because say
uh the experiment's done on tuesday and
it's 64
or you know there's one live cat world
there's one dead cat world now the
quantum fleas start jumping and there
become many many live cat worlds there's
still only one dead cat world so the
probability of an event
would not be determined
after the just after the event it would
keep changing in the future depending on
how much quantum branching
happened
uh
you know in each of those outcomes and
there's no reason whatsoever for that
quantum branching in the different
outcomes to be matched up uh in the same
way
so uh one problem with this toy model
has been pointed out by david wallace um
he said look this branching is going on
all the time um so
you can't really pick a bunch of little
uh regions on the diagonal of the
density matrix and treat them as clearly
separate from each other and count them
up
because
the regions always have a fuzzy edge
they're always in the process of
splitting they've got some off-diagonal
turns connecting them but those are
getting smaller and then you wait a
little longer now smaller regions are
still connected so what are you going to
count it's not like a clear distinct
count
so that's that's a fair point
and then he goes from that says well you
can't count so all bets are off
we get to invent any rule we want
if you have a crafts process outside the
unitary development yes you get to
invent any rule
for that collapse process
but here we're saying what if we don't
what if we just have the unitary time
development
and wallace's argument which i like to
cite because it makes explicit what's
implicit
in the more
formal sounding arguments
namely the strong anthropic
element of the argument
says
we're rational agents we have to decide
what to do and there's some phrase which
philosophical phrase i don't understand
called diacronics consistency basically
it's supposed to mean we're supposed to
be able to make decisions they're
supposed to be reasonably
self-consistent and not
jumping around all the time where we
should have made the other decision at
home that we've known that the quantum
cap was going to have quantum fleas
so he says
if you want to
[Music]
have diachronic consistency then you
need
the born rule
and
the argument is basically
that
if
the quantum probability of an event
is determined once the event's over and
then future branching
which can be
called context if you want
uh has does nothing to do
has no effect on the net probability of
that outcome
then the as gleason showed the only sort
of quantity
that can represent the probability and
obey that rule is the quantum measure
you can think of it as sort of a
conserved fluid
uh flowing and the amount of that fluid
gives you the probability
problem is as we saw if we just start
with the unitary time development
there's no reason for that rule to be
true
and
uh to his credit walls gives sort of an
argument where a skeptic says this
doesn't make any sense it has nothing to
do with the theory you're talking about
and the answer is just it better makes
sense because otherwise the world will
have a completely incomprehensible
probability
so he says we have to have that this
future branching has no effect on the
probability of past
experiments or events because otherwise
it just gets crazy
but
um
in one way or another the same
argument gets used less explicitly
anthropically in all the past um
arguments uh gleason
you says there's non-contextuality
uh independent of splitting into
parallel worlds
zurich himself used additivity where he
says well we can do with symmetry um
argument about a whole bunch of sub
outcomes
of experiments that weren't done
where you make you divide up every
outcome in a bunch of little pieces with
equal measure but we don't
uh do that experiment it's unclear why
that should have anything to do with the
probability we see and
every every week or so there's another
argument that comes out it always comes
down to the same thing if it wasn't
the
born rule
then it would be crazy and we couldn't
make sense of the world but
we have what's supposed to be a complete
theory and we're not supposed to be able
to tell it what result it's going to
give us
it's supposed to tell us what the result
is and then we can check whether that
result agrees with our
experience
uh patrick vanesh has written this up
nicely
describing the implicit antropic
arguments and all these
past
alleged proofs
and he gives a nice analogy he says what
if you
as happened historically
are trying to derive euclid's fifth
posture from the first four and you're
just sure it can be done but
finally you say no actually it can't be
done you can make a consistent
geometry either with projective
postulate or with euclid's postulate and
there is a way of proving it
my favorite example is more from physics
think of black body radiation
if you say black body radiation is
finite you can easily derive from
classical thermodynamics that the
intensity has to go as temperature to
the fourth power
if you assume it's finite
and so many people said well it must be
finite otherwise things are crazy
but classical equipartition says it
ain't finite
it says that things are crazy and
insisting that what we can make the
argument about how the world would be if
it wasn't crazy
is a good way to not discover quantum
mechanics to not be plonked and not find
what that we need a way around classical
equipartition and the way around it is
that the classical physics is false
so let's go to what is counted now i'm
um
getting into jacques mallet's ideas
says look
all you can count is observation
if you can't see it
you can't count it
and there's another key point we don't
really need the absolute counts which
walls has shown don't really exist all
we need is ratios of counts to get
probabilities if we know the ratios of
the counts of different outcomes we can
say what the ratios of probabilities are
and we just normalize we got all the
probabilities
so we're interested in
what constitutes an observation
and here manga says something you know
that really should be kind of obvious
assuming you know the assumption being
that we are in fact part of the physical
world that we are not some sort of
external agent that can intervene in the
world in some way that doesn't obey the
unitary time evolution
so it says an observation is really
computation
performed by
some subsystem of the overall system
and in order to count as a computation
this sort of thing that we call a
thought you have to have some
ingredients like there has to be
uh some memory
you have to some
ability to predict and of course you
can't do that about the entire quantum
state even locally much less globally
but you have to be able to grab
some gross features of the system
sort of stuff i'm seeing looking out of
the window the trees and so on very very
far from a complete description
and
remember what they look like and do some
predictions about how they will behave
and he says
well computations can't work
if there's too much background noise
everybody's
you know tried to do any uh
operating
an old-fashioned um
computer where they had trouble with
noise knows that even digital computers
make a lot of mistakes if there's too
much noise certainly analog computers
make mistakes you can't get a computer
to work if it's swamped with noise
and malwa points out that everything
we're interested in
say the size of our brain and bigger
is in a very high dimensional hilbert
space where every lump in face base
we're going for representing a
macroscopic
outcome
every lump in face space is really
mostly near its boundaries because in
high dimensions surface to volume
gets very big everything
you can't get anything that's in the
middle of the lump
for every single parameter so everything
in one way or another is near the
boundary
and then he says this is the key step
where you
you have a condition on the state not
just a an unconditional argument about
approved
what if there's some sort of
background noise still just quantum
state it's not some other classical
ingredient but just
sort of a background hum kind of white
noise
in the quantum state
what would that do to our ability to
compute or to be computers ourselves
well the only way you can beat
local white noises by doing a little
signal averaging over some volume
let me just try and picture what's going
on here
this is an old-fashioned tv those of you
who never saw crt tv won't recognize
this some of you will
where you just got a bunch of background
noise
and you're trying to see things
well if you have an intense thing you
can see pretty small versions of it
if you have a less intense thing
you can see it but you can't see the
little versions of it
you need to do more coarse grading than
you do out here in order to be able to
see this less intense version
so the amount of core straining you have
to do to see something
depends on how intense it is
or as you might say it depends on psi
michael just letting you know 15 minutes
left 15 minutes we're great we're good
um in fact there'll be tons of time for
um arguments questions
uh so here's what miles says
computations become hard to implement
for a wave at or below some scale
acronym state crowding amplitude levels
the crowded states are the that
background where there's a little bit of
this and a little bit of that with
random phase for all sort of different
possibilities
so he says counterfactuals get ruined
because states can be affected by
incoming waves classical behavior does
not emerge because d coherence cannot
set in
and so
i like to think of it a slightly
different way
just because it's simpler the words are
simpler let's
ignore
the lump in face face
us and the tree you know all the stuff
we're looking at and just think about
the noise
the noise is in thermal equilibrium it's
maximum metric
but as sean carroll described last week
that's a time reversible situation
in a time reversible situation there's
as much re-coherence going on as
decoherence
and re-coherence means the merging of
macroscopically distinct
pasts live cat and dead cat start
interfering why because there's so many
slightly different versions of them in
this
fully occupied state space
that
you can find a version or versions that
match up
in all these weird little details of
their environment will find themselves
and create a merged cat
who had two pasts one live and one dead
so we can't have anything like memory in
a time reversible situation same
argument that sean carroll made
and that means that these
noise-dominated regions
cannot support computations and that
means
thoughts being a type of computation
they can't support observations
so let's ask how many computations if if
there is this sort of background noise
well signal to noise
just classical that's how i made a
living for many years uh goes as the
square root of the number of terms
you've averaged
how many
fine-grained states do you have to
average over to get a signal to noise
bigger than one if locally it's less
than one well you have to average over a
number of fine-grained ingredients
that's proportional to
inversely proportional to the square of
the local signal to noise
which means you get a number of
independent coarse grain averages
that's proportional
to the square of the local signal to
noise
or to slightly change the language the
number of outcomes is proportional to
psi squared
which is a very nice result to get
in unitary quantum mechanics
uh without adding a collapse or
foaming dots or anything like that
and so we are born again
um
a little just uh philosophical remarks
this will leave plenty of turn time for
people to um explain why they don't
believe a word of this
uh i've talked about it is if we're
viewing of course grain screen of course
we're not outside the system viewing it
we are the corresponding screens
ourselves
and
you might object well there's sort of an
anthropic selection left here you're
saying we only get the born
probabilities and a probability rule
that makes sense
if there's this uh sort of white noise
background
aren't we then kind of doing an
anthropic selection to say
there must be that white noise
background in the world well sort of but
it's actually a very mild anthropic
selection saying yeah the state has to
in order to be experienced and make
sense we have to have the right type of
state
but we didn't know what type of state we
were going to have anyway
so that's not so bad
what the other
arguments are doing is essentially an
anthropic selection on theories
saying
any theory that doesn't insist on the
born rule being exactly right is
incomprehensible
and um even though it looks like
the quantum theory we have would not
give the born rule under
prime efficient
so um
i'm arguing that the selection needed is
actually weaker than the typical
anthropic selection we already need
again as sean carroll pointed out
where the hell does this
low entropy world that we live in come
from
there's no
good
uh physical reason that we know of yeah
there may ultimately be one but it seems
much more natural
apache 10 who doesn't like the word
natural
to have a high entropy state
most states are what you'd call high
entropy
and yet somehow by some miracle we're in
a low entropy state it's not all that
hard to say well maybe there's a little
bit of high entropy stuff around too
which is actually much more
natural obviously for there to be than
we are
so um
we're not requiring
um
we just require the existence of our
coherent low entropy state but we
already require that
and we don't
add to that a requirement of the
non-existence of a high entropy
background we just say yeah maybe
there's some high entropy background too
in fact we need it to get the born
probabilities
so that is actually yeah that's the
argument um
i'll leave you with some
uh
links to the
people who have published this argument
um
patrick van nash's version you know some
of us thought of that independently but
jacques malla
really
came up with this wonderful idea and
he's only published it on the archive
but all i'm trying to say is people
should pay attention to it because
i think it's where
it's the best of many not very good
stories as to where the born
probabilities come from
that's it
questions
um so that
i mean it went by a bit fast for me
maybe this would help
um
i mean there's talk about computations
and that only in certain situations can
something compute
yeah
uh and and you could say look there are
observations that aren't in obvious in
the normal sense of computations
computation right galileo drops
a cannonball and a musket ball and says
they they land
within three finger breaths of each
other and you sure yeah in the obvious
senses but then you say gee but you need
memory blah blah blah okay the bunch of
stuff you need for a system to have to
do what we'd call observing
well
just to be a little clearer there's this
bunch of stuff you need to be yourself
yes
yeah and it looks to me like everything
you said goes through just for just for
plain old thermal entropy right if we're
in thermodynamic equilibrium
there ain't going to be any observers
okay there won't be absolutely
absolutely thermodynamic equilibrium
right so but if i just replace
thermodynamic
entropy
in this argument i mean i'm not sure
what i'm supposed to get out of it i
mean
what what does it tell me about
probabilities that the fact that i can't
observe
if the thermodynamic entropy is in
equilibrium sure but what what is i i
just i'm sorry i just don't see the
connection what it tells you is the
conceptual connection the ordinary
classical signal to noise considerations
give you
[Music]
that the probabilities that would emerge
from this that is the relative numbers
of different
object versions of you observing
different outcomes would go as psi
squared it wouldn't go as something else
it would go with psi squared and that is
a good thing to have emerge from a
theory because it is what we observe
i mean let me all right maybe i can try
it this way okay we know that in many
worlds there'll be worlds where you
don't see born statistics for sure
sure they'll be everything but
and they'll be everything they'll be
worlds with observers that observe
everything
yes signal the noise won't get rid of
them
so i'm doing this i just can't see
what's being
how that signaled the noise the argument
the argument is that the vast majority
of worlds
of experiences
will look like the born probabilities
what's the measure by which you just
measured vast majority that's what i'm
not understanding you're not counting
worlds
we're we're sort of counting worlds
we're counting um
pieces of the density matrix that could
represent a computation that have
reasonably good signal to noise and
therefore could be treated could be
experienced as
a thought as opposed to just being a
fuzz
and so
it's
if the off diagonal terms went to zero
more cleanly then we could count
worlds but um
they're fuzzy so we have to count
good enough
worlds
um
let me go back and just ask you
is the problem with
the toy model clear enough the you know
the the problem with you know it looks
like there are probabilities there
vanessa's shown that those are
consistent probabilities they're just
crazy
um
and they don't correspond to our
experience
that would be
world counting
if the worlds were a little cleaner and
more uncountable like in our toy model
saying there are fuzzy edges because of
noise
that affects the problem in the you you
i don't see how that affects
the problem of counting measure when
you're basically counting d coherent
lumps
we're only computing we're only
only counting lumps that
have been coarse-grained enough
to have
decent signal to noise if it's if
there's a lump
but it's constantly got input from
off-diagonal terms
you know remember time reversibility
popping up
onto the diagonal the same way
in the part of the state we usually
think about a diagonal term keeps
drifting out
of
you know losing off diagonals
uh
what the other time reversed is that
very small off diagonals show up and
show up as a whole bunch of quantum
interference terms between things that
you thought were separate before
that would mean
that those little separate things could
have not represent memories
remember that
think of how hard it is to predict
quantum future
what if it was equally hard
to remember the quantum path which is
what it would be
if
uh
you were in a noise-dominated regime
where time reversibility would apply
okay then
well i think that we run out of time for
this um
q a session so let's thank the speaker
again
and let's reconvene here in
five minutes